that would have been in and out out of
California
and it's a California staple
[Music]
all right this is a good one
um I'm sure you guys have heard about
this
it is about McDonald's wages going up oh
cool 22. is that cool yeah
I mean to me it's it's a it's a cool and
a not cool oh because because like if I
was a 16 year old right and I'm like yo
man minimum wage is what like how much
is it in California right now right 15.
and you just start working and you get a
[ __ ] racist 22 you'll just be like
yeah yeah all right now now yeah yeah is
that a bad part no no that's good for
the 16 year old right is it good for the
greater economy of La I'm not too sure
is it good for the small business owner
it's just for California is it good for
the small business owner who's already
having a hard [ __ ] time paying 15 an
hour because his business is about to
[ __ ] die I think it's just fast food
it's just fast food it's like just fast
food yeah oh it's just all fast food and
it's it's specific restaurants within
the fast food industry oh oh because
this is part of [ __ ] Gavin nuisance's
[ __ ] plan
he signed off on it but he wasn't he
wasn't the one who wrote the Bill like
someone else did and then
um and it's interesting because it's not
just as simple as saying like oh the the
wages are going to go up the bill
establishes a panel so it's like a brand
new panel with members appointed by the
governor made up of Union reps employers
and business Advocates and them together
will decide whether the wage goes up
which they are going to make it could go
up to the 22 and then they have a right
to increase it annually so what are the
factors that are going to say these
restaurants are entitled to pay 22 or do
we have a list already of which
restaurant that's what what uh
restaurants are pissed about is because
it'll apply to some but not all like
it's weird it's like some that baked
bread aren't affected some that there's
like this weird little thing so I'm
making bread with no carb this is the
place where I'm like
this is where I go oh that's not so good
so to the individual who might be
getting some hey you do you good for you
right but then the the overall ecosystem
and on top of that who are The
Gatekeepers that's what I'm concerned
about it's that uh panel that they're
making and that's what sucks is that the
details are really unfair to different
restaurants like it's more based on
franchises so if a place has a hundred
restaurants then that's considered oh
you're part of the group that has to
like do this thing but but it's not fair
because one let's say you own one
McDonald's right you're super affected
and then another guy owns 30 restaurants
that are not franchises he's not
affected exactly yeah does that make
sense who's gonna go work for him now
he's going to lose employees I'm like
I'm gonna work at McDonald's you can pay
15 an hour same [ __ ] I'm gonna do at
McDonald's and then at the same time
yeah McDonald's has already made it
really clear that this is not going to
be good for the workers and when they're
the ones saying that that's basically
saying we're going to let them go
because oh 100 yeah yeah temporarily
also it's basically just going to push
them to all automated Services well
they're either gonna and it's it's kind
of like a this is a big uh long-term
thing but like they're not what they're
just kind of saying is that even though
you're gonna they're gonna be required
to pay 22 dollars an hour to these
employees they're not necessarily
meriting that much value in their work
to the company if that makes sense like
they're not doing 22 an hour worth of
work in their numbers in their figures
I'm assuming they're gonna probably have
less people show people how to use
machines
exactly automation it's just like what
happened to the car washers Union like a
long time ago where they unionized some
guy unionized all the car washers to uh
band together to like get the same
amount of pay and that was the birth of
automatic car washes wow yeah so there's
even McDonald's now you go in like most
of them are automated and then before
when you go into McDonald's like I
remember when I grew up going to
McDonald's there's a table and there's
like maybe five registers now there's
maybe one and then there's like four of
the automated ones and then when you go
to a non-busy McDonald's and there's a
human being that's like supposed to
stand outside and help you with the
machine the automated stuff sometimes
they [ __ ] it up and I'm like stop
helping me let me do my you know that
this McDonald's has two [ __ ] ordering
systems you pull up to one and you're
like hello hello they're like go to the
next one and then you go to the next one
and there's a there's a a a a area you
could talk to them oh it's [ __ ] weird
it's like they didn't take down the old
one
so you have you you sit there and you
see everybody pulled in Just In
transition I know right you know who
deserves the 22 the earpiece
[ __ ] because that [ __ ]
is at the front register
oh yeah and you want that with that with
that and then he's like back and forth
right and this will still throwing the
burgers in the microwave and [ __ ] yeah
oh the night the night dude tonight guys
you got the McDonald's multitasker that
fool deserves no for sure the night guy
because he has to deal with all the
Stoners all the drunk yeah yeah they
can't even say to order right be
compensated for that dude and sometimes
they're stoned but crushing it yeah you
know like how can you be stoned scared
to stoners
but it's crazy it's a tick tock Trend
right now to get these guys to like
break um what's called Break character
oh yeah so when you pull up to these
fast food places you know two in the
morning they're just starting they're
they're getting [ __ ] with all the time
now that's like the new thing I'm gonna
get them to reach through the window and
[ __ ] me up so I can record it so I can
go viral they always [ __ ] with fast food
people too because remember the soft
serve thing the challenge they would
order a McDonald's soft serve and then
when they hand them the cone they grab
it from the [ __ ] ice cream I don't
wanna [ __ ] with people
they do deserve suddenly we talk about
[ __ ] Tick Tock challenges we're like
hey make it 25 yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ]
people are [ __ ] one thing that is
another thing that could will probably
happen is um the prices go up yeah it's
already going up dude it [ __ ] cost me
23 bucks for two meals at um Carl's Jr
eight dollars a burger
yeah dude and it's just gonna keep going
up yeah it is and then uh and then this
is like the bigger one that could
possibly happen but I doubt it the uh
McDonald's would just flat out leave
California yeah oh no I love McDonald's
okay McDonald's leaves California we
gotta shut down the whole state and
rework this from the top somebody [ __ ]
up yeah okay we can't be [ __ ] having
McDonald's leave that's a whoa whoa whoa
moment everybody needs to chill the [ __ ]
out that's [ __ ] crazy
well there's hell of companies I have
left right like [ __ ] testing
absolutely absolutely in and out almost
bounced too that would have been in and
out out of California that was almost
like it's a cow a California staple it
was it was during the covet thing when
they were like forcing vaccinations they
didn't want to force their employers
oh what the [ __ ] dude this was making
the stupidest decisions ever yeah I'm a
nuisance I think it's the walkness
politicians because they're like making
up all these [ __ ] rules that it's
like who's asking for this and then
truck drivers too so it's like there's a
double whammy this year the truck
drivers and the the fast food thing so
like truck drivers now they can't be
self-employing more they got to be W-2
and they're like on strike so if they're
not bringing stuff into the you know you
know what I think California is so like
in theory they have great initiatives
but the execution's always horrible
because think about it right you want to
trust the government that they'll carry
through but if you go to any government
services like the DMV it's horribly
[ __ ] done so that's why they might
have great initiatives like hey let's
try to get our workers to get more pay
let's try to balance the scales they
have great ideas but they [ __ ] suck
every single time to try to solve it
it's also like they're all about
perception dude it's like a like that
white lady that wears a dashiki and is
like all about Africa but like doesn't
want to hang out with black people you
know they're like nervous around black
people that's California dude that's
California bro that's California
Keys dude you just got can't wait sorry
that's the [ __ ] truth dude
it's the truth also isn't there a
[ __ ] point where like you know what
you're like you're with their homies or
whatever and they're like hey this is
kind of cool right now like us driving
to wherever and then some one of the
stupid ass homies might bring up an idea
like hey you guys want a [ __ ]
mountain bike whatever like no shut the
[ __ ] up this is we got AC this is a cool
car let's just go on this road trip like
in the 90s like California was cool
they need to have a shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] like position where someone has
a wife no you just shut the [ __ ] up yeah
cause McDonald's gonna leave us and then
I was gonna [ __ ] leave us leave
everything that should be the measure of
politicians from now on in our state
like did you make McDonald's prices go
up or down
any politician that makes in and out
leave they're gonna they should they
should they they should revoke their
Californian calls there's something
called the Golden Era and it starts with
the golden arches you know what I'm
saying yeah
and keep it just keep it like that this
is cool right now yeah we need to hire
the shut the [ __ ] up guys yeah like the
remember the [ __ ] uh what is like 89
cheeseburger that was [ __ ] cool they
made songs about it you know [ __ ]
leave it like that now it's [ __ ] I
don't know two dollars now God they used
to give you just 40 nuggets for free or
some [ __ ] yeah you would like buy 10
nuggets and be like hey do you want 30
more
no I don't know when they had like 39
Cent shoes we were 29 hamburgers and
then Vietnamese people and Garden Grove
you you were walking there and they
would they would buy 20 because that was
the maximum you could buy 20 at a time
eat it throughout the week that would be
like the best like that's like the best
way to be like hey America is a land of
opportunity come over here and that was
that's cool but you just didn't maintain
it how we [ __ ] it up but now that
mountainbound guy the guy in the car
because he didn't get hurt he's gonna
let everyone else know hey they didn't
listen to me they didn't hear me so now
everyone hits everyone else in the car
now he's cranky yeah he's pissed because
I feel like what ended up happening is
like people like death on healthy it's
like [ __ ] all these Hall monitors did
you go do sit-ups then I know
yeah and don't eat it every day Jesus
Christ right the Papa John's the Papa
John's thing man the same thing it
doesn't it doesn't make sense are they
trying to make California into this
vegan ass like [ __ ] hippie place
where everybody [ __ ] meets each other
and be like hey this is my [ __ ] name
and I'm also Aries and like you have to
say that on your profile [ __ ] that's
some people's ideal California and they
will do that by force that's not even
the California I know that's all the
[ __ ] transplants that came here
because they don't feel accepted by the
[ __ ] Christian Community that they
live in and they [ __ ] want to come
out here and be like yo now I'm free
it's like you just making up an idea of
what you think California is get the
[ __ ] out of here
[Music]